the Canadian Space Agency is actually
gonna come today and feed us the food
that astronauts are eating in space
right there are countless movies about
the heroism and excitement of being an
astronaut these movies focus on
adventure risk-taking and what happens
when things go wrong though these
high-stakes scenarios are exciting they
ignore the fascinating day-to-day
experiences of astronauts that are
realistic but also incredible today
we're going to show you exactly what
astronauts are eating in space right now
in order to stay alive and stay sane
so we are here with Natalie from the
Canadian Space Agency what do we what
are we gonna be doing here NASA has a
standard menu that they provide on the
space station so today you're gonna be
trying a collection of American and
Canadian foods okay we're gonna actually
blindfold you sleep okay taste the space
for you too and guess what your ears I
assume it will be in nutrition it feels
like plastic I don't want to put the
actually dehydrated
okay so interesting thing in space
people have a difficult time smelling
when they first get into space because
all the fluid shifts towards their head
those they're not exposed to gravity
they would really struggle to smell
things and to taste things especially in
the first few weeks I'm thinking like
broccoli it's red red pepper
what we look for when we're looking for
space food is that there's no fridge or
freezer on Space Station so we need
products like that flex
[Music]
is it actually it tastes like curry
literally is any like me like a nutty
flavor I'm getting like I literally you
like something I love it's a chicken
cashew curry Wow
how long on average are the in-space
like usually for six months at a time
okay so it's nice to have like a variety
of meals otherwise you'd go like kind of
a little crazy right and that's one of
the reasons why we have a lot of variety
on orbit so that people don't get bored
so there's the psychological side of
things but then there's also the
physiological side of things so we
designed the menu so that there's three
meals a day and a snack can we kind of
plan for like an eight day menu cycles
there's three meals a day
how long do astronauts usually sleep so
they are scheduled for like an
eight-hour sleep period but they don't
necessarily sleep that pure right but
it's like scheduled for you do try to
keep track of their work schedule as
much as possible because you don't want
them to overwork Yeah right but they got
into some work I mean that spares
dollars you know but usually form is not
that they don't do enough work yeah
yeah that's right oh my god it tastes
like hot dog oh it's shrimp shrimp right
shrimp cocktail
yeah this is one of the most popular
dishes on that it should and so the
reason this is so popular is because
it's spicy when astronauts have a head
wood fluid ship and they feel like they
have this head cold something like this
that's got a lot of spice and flavor but
on Space Station there's a water
dispenser that dispenses warm and OH
it flies dehydrated and then you add
water warms my hydrated trips are cold
[Music]
not capri-sun
may I set the straw so this is a space
straw and it actually has a lock on it
so that when you're in space oh I feel
velcro is that because you guys stick it
to a wall that's right so you don't want
to have your food floating all over the
station that just tastes like every
fruit and one I think it's my raspberry
I can give you a hint
okay two fruits like me and you match to
peach mine I love how this is just so
space looks bugs but then you're like oh
yeah no it's a space person George yeah
on about - Troy - yes so when you think
about our ders what kind of seafood
would use Oh crab crab but it's crab
that's brown it's like a crab pate is
there any refrigeration in space there's
a very small refrigerator that they can
hose for condiments
what about like once you open this pate
so sometimes crews will get together for
to celebrate special occasions just like
we do on the ground for David
saint-jacques he's gonna be in space too
Christmas New Year so their crew would
usually get together for anyone who was
not Canadian if you haven't tasted this
what Doudna is it no it hasn't texture
of tuna falling apart but it tastes like
me yeah okay so this is a Canadian
product Oh salmon maple syrup yes do
this space agencies just all work
together I think that's one of the main
benefits of International Space Station
is just national corporation rights HS
you go to Peru ski but the moon news
NECA did Paris keep no this Nike yeah
and you gave it up you ski I give it up
uh so you Russia and when you speak to
astronauts official when they come back
from space they say when you look at the
earth yeah any planning borders and that
in the perspective you must have yeah
interesting is that David saint-jacques
mission is called perspective oh wow so
Greg yeah oh also the water is so
essential and David saint-jacques
they'll be going up with water so
actually when he flies in his rocket
it's just to bring the crew up and
there's a very small amount of room in
that vehicle for other things and then
they have other vehicles that will go to
space that just takes it just lies
though someone's in there no so there's
a Russian vehicle that's unmanned called
the progress and then the Americans are
now flying commercial vehicles
there's two companies that are flying
commercial vehicles is it Elon Musk one
of them yes how does it be talked it has
so that's a good question and depending
on on the vehicle sometimes they'll use
the Canada arm to dock the Canada arm I
don't know if you guys know about that
as a national treasure it's on our money
without the Canada and to which is on
Space Station we wouldn't have been able
to put the space station together so it
literally have to piece all the
different components so it being on
money is like well we're oh yeah it's
something to be very very proud of you
asked about water and so we do ship some
water onto Space Station but then we
also do a lot of recycling so all the
water that's on Space Station
will get collected and recycled there's
a systems up there that will collect
urine urine so that will become your
water for the coffee
Wow
where does the number two go not
recycled right I think it's a space
difference is me oh wow so the
environmental control system will
collect all the condensate so you know
when you breathe the oxygen in the air
maybe one day our houses all do that too
that's one of the reasons that we have
space station is to sort of figure out
how we're going to like Laura
further on long story short the future
involves drinking your own pee so
David's a Jack's a Canadian astronaut
him he was going to space on social
media grip at all the description below
because he's gonna be documenting all
that his preparation of going to space
all the scene interesting things that we
were just sort of starting to tackle
here he will be talking about like the
idiosyncrasies of going to space so well
put all the description there even
follow along I know we will all right
well that was our Tatum full of space
food I'm very satiated want to say thank
you so much Natalie for coming on
canadian space agency for allowing us to
chow down and all your food pleasure
thanks for watching it's a so cool going
space is obviously something we should
all be thinking about there's a game
perspective and yeah thank you so much
James